[Music]
hello to all of you our Su TV family and
friends welcome to I'd like to know our
Bible question and answer program at and
this is one of our favorite shows here
my name is C Murray I'm in the company
of Pastor David Salazar and Pastor
Steven bore and of course you're with us
and that makes everything wonderful and
complete as mentioned this is our Bible
question and answer program we take your
questions by the grace of God we answer
them from the word of God under the egis
of the holy spirit of God and we make
you that promise that whenever you send
a question in we will do the requisite
study put in the time to answer your
questions from the word of God you don't
need the opinions of men we're a little
too late in Earth's history for that
what we all need is answers for our
lives from the word of God and that's
what we pledge to give to you each and
every time that you send your questions
in should you like to get in on the fun
and send in a question we invite you to
do so we encourage you to do so by
sending your questions to
TVM tv.org that is TV
s
mv.org and we will get to your questions
just as soon as we possibly can we make
you that promise Pastor bore would you
please um go to the Lord in prayer for
us and with us and then we'll launch out
in our in our program for today Father
in heaven we come before you with
humility yet with
confidence because we come in the name
of Jesus Amen we ask that you will bless
this program that you will give us
Divine wisdom to answer the questions
appropriately from your word that you
will bless those who are watching the
program that they might be blessed as
well and we thank you for the privilege
of prayer and we anticipate your answer
in the precious name of Jesus amen amen
and amen amen this first question comes
from Henry P it is a question that pops
up every now and again having to do with
inspiration I remember going back to the
70s when there was much uh questions
about many questions about um uh
plagiarism and all those things that
people were trying to to sort of hang on
Ellen White and then every now and again
it comes back and it is leg a legitimate
question uh the authority of of her
writings so she asked this is Henry uh
he asked rather the argument has been
stated that since Ellen White has not
specified which part of her writings are
inspired that therefore we can only
trust the sections where she says it was
shown to
me as the true inspired sections of her
writings how would you respond to such
such a
statement well the bottom line is that
um originally the great controversy was
in a series called uh spiritual gifts
and then after that spiritual prophecy
was an expansion great controversy is
the greatest expansion uh the early
writings of Ellen White uh at least once
every page she said I saw it was shown
to me Etc uh so great controversy uh
doesn't have those statements I saw and
it was shown to me and Ellen White
explained the reason it's because when
Ellen White wrote uh it was very
unpopular to claim to be a prophet and
so by saying I was shown or I saw uh it
would turn off a large group of people
that were down on the idea of visions
and prophecies and so um you know she
with her consent uh the these
Expressions were taken out not because
uh those books or those articles were
not inspired but in order not to offend
people and so that people would read her
books mhm I I kind of like also to use
the illustration of the Bible um the
Apostle Paul for example in 1
Corinthians
7:25 he says this verse not concerning
virgins I have not commanded of the Lord
yet I give my judgment as one that had
obtained mercy of the Lord to be
faithful so apparently he's going to
just suggest what many could say or is
his own opinion right but it's really a
experience of humility of humbleness and
the apostle Paul in the same chapter at
the very end as he finishes his
presentation he says this uh speaking
you know says uh but if she's happier if
she so abide after my judgment and I
think also that I have the spirit of God
now he is implying that you know in a
very humble way that is the Lord who
inspired him to speak and to say these
things and no one really questions the
authenticity of the inspiration of the
scriptures of the of Paul but to you
know to to pin this concept that Paul is
speaking out of inspiration and to say
that this portion is not inspired for
example will be very very wrong it will
be uh trying to say that some things of
the Bible are not inspired when the word
of God and the Bible is very clear that
the spirit of God moved upon the minds
of the you know the prophets and they
wrote according to the what the
inspiration gave them Concepts to
understand and to write in the same way
the same spirit is the one that came uh
over LG white and it's the same exact
same way that she expresses the
inspiration of the Holy Spirit to write
the things that she wrote it's it's a
matter of understanding that as a humble
uh individual as one that is the servant
of the Lord she would not claim to
herself to have the
you know she would not claim herself to
be in the same league as the Bible but
it's not necessarily because she was
inferior or not inspired just simply
because of the spirit of humility that
she had just like the Apostle Paul also
never claimed to be you know equal or
above or like Christ he was always a
humble individual so this is where I
think that people that have an issue
with the spirit prophecy where they're
not really seeing that the inspiration
that inspired the scripture is the same
inspiration the same holy spirit that
Inspire her is really just trying are
are really just trying to pin her uh her
condition as a prophet uh only because
she's not continually being said or
mentioned in these words of I saw where
I was shown so it's really just a matter
of understanding and inspiration to
White is the same inspiration that came
to the prophets in the apostles in the
Old Testament or in the New Testament
for that matter I think a lot of it has
to do with how inspiration is received
and understood Satan is a a a very great
counterfeit the Adventist Church grew up
1844 got its name in the early 1860s
there were several churches in fact many
of the churches that that got their
start during that time were all started
by or were Led Out by a prophet or a
person who claimed thems themselves to
be a prophet
consequently uh the idea of so many
people starting so many religions with
so many ideologies really fell into
disfavor and this goes back to what you
were talking about she she realized that
she was you know your Mary Baker Eddy
and you had science you had the Mormons
you had all of these churches this flood
of churches all beginning in the mid
19th century as we did all being led by
quote a prophet and so she she she took
pains during her lifetime she didn't use
the word that much uh she didn't allow
it to be used in her presence that much
because she was trying to distinguish
what her role was as a leader uh as a
voice of God from the common designation
of prophet which everybody and their
brother had during that time uh so she
did adjust some things so that we
weren't caught up in the the flood of
things that were going on during during
that
time if you read her writings you you
you you got to be impressed that a
person with with such limited
education comes up with terminologies
and ideologies and mindsets and and
things that were so far Advanced Beyond
on not only her time but her her
educational level um so just because she
didn't specifically say God showed me or
my angel showed me or my angel told me
which he did use uh which which which uh
is in um uh some of writing story
Redemption comes to mind uh steps of
Christ comes to mind uh doesn't mean
that what she was saying was not
inspired by by the Lord you know if you
use this argument that only when she
said it was shown to me only those p are
inspired you would have to discard uh
the entire conflict series yes because
she doesn't use the Expression I was
shown even once so you would have to get
rid of Patriarchs and Prophets prophets
and Kings Desire of Ages uh and the Acts
of the Apostles and great controversy as
being fully inspired doesn't mean you
would read them but uh you know the
placing this test that I was sh it was
shown to meh um you know there are
prophets that never said I was it was
shown to me does it mean that they were
not inspired uh fully by the Spirit uh
you know the bottom line is that the
Holy Spirit when the Holy Spirit uh
directs a prophet we can be certain that
the inspir the degree of inspiration is
the same yes because if it's a would you
say that the spirit you know he's um you
know that's fully inspired because the
spirit directed the mind and then in
another occasions you would say well the
same Holy Spirit did but it's a lesser
inspiration
you know it doesn't sense and and so
this idea that only when she said I was
it was shown to me or I saw uh that only
Those portions are inspired you would
have to get rid of most of her writings
yeah and you know people have this thing
that you know what makes them come to
these situations these conclusions or
these ideas is really because they don't
want to accept things that to them are
problem you know a lot of times it comes
down to that they don't want to accept a
guidance for Doctrine or information or
beliefs or changes in lifestyle whatever
it might be and because I have a problem
with what is given as a counsel to us
they want to say you know what this is
not inspired to reject light that God
has given us for our benefit for our
growth to know the truth to not be
deceived and so I really find that
disturbing that unfortunately among many
Adventists today the idea of the the
wrers of white as as not inspired or as
not being valid for our nurturing for
our growth for our counil it's really
sad and really leads us into confusion
and to reject the sound doctrines of of
our word of the word of God I mean
eventually we can you know reject her
writings we start rejecting a lot of
other things that even inspiration in
the Bible is clearly shown and Jesus
confirms or helps us to see even more
clear so I I feel that um you know we
have to be careful why the reason you
know and and not not try to find a way
to excuse ourselves and to reject
something just because it doesn't go
along with what we want to say or think
I remember sitting in a seminar years
ago and I'll do this very quickly um
where a person was was defending Ellen
White uh and someone had said well she
took this from somebody else's work she
plagiarizes and uh so the person brought
in the original copy what Ellen White
said and then they brought in a copy
that showed where she she took several
lines here she skipped this part because
it was error and then picked it back up
on the other side so that also is how
inspiration functions this this was
truth so she used it this was not truth
she omitted it this was truth she came
back to it uh so you know we we've got
to give uh D I say the holy Spirit some
slack on this you know he works on the
mind he works on the heart he he just
because it it does not say I was shown
does not mean it's less of a an inspired
work than than what was under I it was
and Ellen White admitted openly that she
used historians for example you know if
historians agreed with what show what
was she show what she was shown in
Vision yes why try to do it from stretch
right right invent be practical if a
historian you know wrote uh some
information that she saw in vision is
correct why not use it why write it from
scratch um time for a commercial break
all righty important one uh a few years
ago I did an anchor School of Theology
uh on the spirit of Prophecy and the
result was uh two volumes of study notes
uh that deal with all sorts of
accusations against Ellen White all
sorts of issues relating to Ellen White
I'll just show this to you um on the
screen and this is available from
Secrets unsealed the first volume is
basically uh material that I prepared
and the second volume is resource
material mostly uh written about Ellen
White by others or written by Ellen
White about about her own Ministry so
these are available from Secrets
unsealed and the good news is that they
are also available online if you
download our app uh you can uh download
these for free and use them for your own
personal edification yeah this is good
stuff uh if I may give you your flowers
while you yet live uh well written well
done easy to understand and uh it will
enhance your your your Bible study and
certainly your study of the spirit of
Prophecy and the writings of lmg white
all right let's see if we can squeeze
one more in in the time that is yet
allotted to us this one coming from
South Africa hello South Africa and
hello Gracie from South Africa hi I
heard Pastor step bore say in one of his
lectures that before the flood
that before the flood because humans
lived such long a span of years Earth
probably had millions of inhabitants we
know from the bi biblical account that
the flood was a global event we also are
taught that Noah preached the word of
God for repentance and the anti delians
had opportunity through his preaching to
repent my question is how did Noah
Noah's preaching span the whole world
okay well let's uh address the first uh
question first part of the question MH
uh and that is how do we know that uh
the planet had probably millions of
populations uh first of all God said in
Genesis be fruitful and multiply and
fill the Earth MH um and secondly uh the
the individuals live to be almost a
thousand years old some of them MH how
many children can a 969 year old man
have
uh you know when they were 3 or 400 they
were still adolescence yeah yeah and
Ellen White says that they had uh 20
times the vital energy that we have
today that's right she says that if that
wasn't true the the human race would
have become extinct is what she says so
uh the point is when you do the math and
I had a statistician do it once uh there
were obviously millions and millions of
people because they populated the entire
Earth so so that is is uh the support
for that particular part of the question
uh how did uh Noah preach the message on
a global scale if there was population
all over the world usually we think of
the uh inhabitants before the flood in
evolutionary terms yeah cavemen we think
of them they were cavemen and they had C
hatchets and they were killing D
dinosaurs and we have the The
evolutionary concept of individuals that
live before the flood let me ask you how
much could a scientist do in a
scientific lab uh in 800 years I mean
lot they were much more intelligent
absolutely they had a far more advanced
technology than we have today that's the
key I'm not going to say I'm not going
to say that they had television sets and
they had the internet but why not
because they were super intelligent
Ellen White states that Adam was studied
the mysteries of light and sound and of
course the modern technology is based on
light and sound and so the problem is
with our mindset that we are thinking
that the people that lived before the
flood were kind of ignorant they didn't
have any education and uh and the
opposite is true absolutely and also you
know in the sense of of of like you said
a lot of times we think of the world
that was there I mean back then as it is
today with the way that the oceans and
the continents whatever that is you know
and and we're thinking no how could they
have traveled I mean they didn't have
you know but the truth of the matter is
that the world was much different Before
the Flood the flood changed dramatically
the conditions of the earth true and so
uh most likely that there was not these
these vast oceans and and so what I'm
saying is that that even they the need
to travel they need to to pass the
knowledge of the Gospel or the message
of of the flood it reached Nations it
reached every inhabitant of the world
there was a knowledge and the
rejection by the knowledge uh of of that
flood brought destruction also another
point is that Noah was not
alone in spreading the truth Enoch it
says the Bible he who was you know you
know he he foretold of the coming of the
Lord he foretold of of the elements that
are coming and even Noah's father worked
to until the very or lived until the
very year the the flood basically so he
had other Godly men who died before the
flood but also helped spread the gospel
or the truth about the end of the world
so God did not just destroy the human
flesh you know the human inhabitants of
this world uh without then being warned
about the destruction that is a fair God
and he would have given the warning yes
well said no I I'll toss in another name
Methuselah who who lived up until the BL
so you had not just one man you had a
race of people who were moving across
the Earth and spreading the the the
gospel Noah gets the the the the star
because he's he he's he's uh doing the
boat building and doing some other
things but you had a large number of
people who were standing for the Lord
and and and warning the world of what
was going on um and and and the thing
about it you've got a jettison this
caveman idea from your mind right uh and
then it becomes a little bit clearer as
we go clear as we go back towards
the first man man actually doesn't get
weaker he gets stronger uh as as you
well Inon and uh that accounts for a lot
of the the scientific discoveries the
the um you know Ellen White talks about
amalgamation of man and Beast and some
people think was man with Beast no man
and Beast so things are going on
scientifically that uh we we can only
dream about today uh because man's
brains were so much a lot of things
could be shared orally because man could
hold so much more information then then
he does now we're kind of a long way
down you know Ellen White stated that
the people before the flood had
photographic memories whatever they saw
and heard they could retrieve yeah which
is amazing now what happened at the time
of the flood all the technology was lost
yes and it's taken all this time to get
it back to get some of it back uh you
know it's kind of like if the world was
destroyed
and only I
survived I'll tell you what there would
be no internet there would be no some TV
there would be no television there would
be no technology and would take a long
time to get it back because I don't have
the foggiest idea how it works yeah how
how
bu that's true a lot was lost during
that flood I mean uh and of course the
the Atlantic Ocean the Pacific Ocean
these things we see now didn't exist
then they weren't part of that world uh
so you know if if you kind of sit down
and work your mind through it it it
makes a lot of sense and uh uh you can
see how these things uh could be and how
it could have but it it's it's a good
question and by the way Word of Mouth
travels very fast amen amen that's right
that's right it could it could make it
all the way around the world very
quickly even if you don't have
airplanes or or Internet or email or
whatever whatever that may have been
praise the Lord let's see we've got
three minutes and change on the clock
let's see we can't at least uh dip our
toes in the water of this next question
which comes from Dana from Florida dear
Pastor bour could you please explain
Paul's meaning of Colossians chapter 2:
16 and 17 Pastor if you have that we can
read it rather than going with the
question because um it has to do with
Sabbath and we'll just walk our way
through it and I'm sure we'll we'll
answer our questions it says this second
uh Colossians 2:16 and 17 let no man
therefore judge your judge you in meat
or in drink or in respect expect of a
holiday or the new moon or the Sabbath
days which are a shadow of things to
come but the body is of
Christ okay well my name was mentioned I
have a temptation to delegate this
responsibility as the president of
Secrets
unsealed but but I'll just give a brief
uh comment and then you guys can kick in
we might need a little more time at our
next program uh but you know there were
uh sabbaths that were ceremonial there
were yearly sabbaths uh and there were
also the weekly Sabbath and the Apostle
Paul here here is referring to
ceremonial sabbaths he's not referring
to the seventh day Sabbath uh so that's
the short answer uh by the way I do have
in one of my study notes a full study of
Colossians chapter 2: 16- 17 so I would
encourage everyone to download the app
uh because on the app you'll find
everything I've written the study notes
and also all of the presentations now
you guys your
turn well you know it's like you
mentioned you gave the the the basic of
it but it's important that he's speaking
in regards to things that are
not uh that are in preference or in your
own um decision if you will that are not
contradictory to the law of the Lord or
to the Bible to the principles of the
word of God so if you have the desire to
you know uh have a day of of dedication
to the Lord if you decide to you know
pray to God and and make a special day
of the week a time where you can commune
with him and do maybe uh fasting or
something of that nature he's regarding
that aspect of your spiritual life as
okay but is not in any way telling uh
someone that the Sabbath the holy day of
the Lord the 7day Sabbath is you know
turned away with is nothing to do with
what established as the love of God
because it's immutable it cannot change
Dana we're going to make you a promise
and a pledge we're going to take this up
on Next program at the very beginning
because it is it is worth uh answering
in detail there's a lot of things about
this particular text that have been
misinterpreted and mishandled and we
need to walk our way through it so uh
you come back next time and we'll try to
take a look at at your question and
answer it in detail and take our time
with it again our time has slipped into
eternity allow me in closing to wish you
both Grace and peace through our Lord
and Savior Jesus Jesus Christ we'll see
you again soon bye-bye and God bless